And I will resist the urge to try to organize a meetup during your wedding. I mean, we can definitely record a podcast while we're down there for sure. I mean, that's just, why would we not do that? I would say that I definitely think you and I are going to be talking a lot less about C++ and a lot more about other languages over the course of this year. Welcome to ADSB the podcast episode 221 recorded on January 22nd, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we make our 2025 predictions and chat about a plethora of other random topics. And then we're going to get some 2025 hot takes.
I mean, technically the time this comes out, it's gonna be like mid February, but but it is January when recording this folks. So we're gonna get some. Will it be as good as the Empire Strikes Back, which was the prediction of like, I don't know, 2023. That was I mean, I like to put a what do you call it? A teaser episode or like a featured episode I think is what it's called and
I think that was episode one 50 no episode 150 was Is C++ dead? Which actually it might have been let's quickly go check because I actually I put the Star Wars music Disney hasn't come after me yet. Let's quickly go check because I actually I put the Star Wars music. Disney hasn't come after me yet. Let's see if we. Yeah, that was the one where we we we subpotted Oxide and Friends, but I think the the Star Wars one.
Let's see. I think I put it in the title Star. Oh, yeah. Episode one eleven. Yeah, episode one eleven. When was this? January 6th of 2023. And I put the Star Wars music. I replaced our little jingle with the, I can't remember, it wasn't the Imperial March.
It was just the opening theme. That was, that was, did it come to fruition? I guess we've never done a retro on whether our predictions came true or not. There's a funny C++ committee story that I'm not 100% sure if I should tell, so I'll go ahead and tell it. a former chair of a subgroup who upon the first meeting where he came back to his subgroup after he retired his chair when he entered the room he had playing on his phone the Imperial March. It was just perfect.
I know someone, my former boss walked down the wedding aisle to the Imperial March Oh, that's a great idea. That's a great. What are you gonna walk down the wedding the wedding aisle to? Uh, I haven't thought that far to be honest. I don't know some classic wedding music I don't know. It's up to Shima whatever she she wants. I'm not too particular about the music that I walk down the aisle to. I mean we're gonna be on the beach looking out at the ocean. So I guess maybe my back will be to the ocean. Everyone else will be looking out at the ocean. Yeah, because you want the good pictures. You want the good pictures. You're not gonna get to see the ocean. No ocean for you. Yeah, yeah. Anyways, we'll get to 2025 predictions and hot takes from Bryce in a moment. What was the meetup thing you were gonna mention?
So, I'm planning some meetups or, let me put it this way. I got some travel coming up this year and my new philosophy is that when I travel, I'm going to try to find meetups to speak at because why not? I'll give a brief list of some of the places that I'm going to, some of which I've already got meetups set up in, some of which I'm looking for people who might be interested in helping me arrange a meetup. So in February, I'm going to be in Paris and I've reached out to some of the C++ meetup people in Paris, still waiting to hear back and get something set up there. When in February? It's gonna be... I'm sorry,
it's not February. I am wrong about that. That's gonna be in March. In February I'm gonna be in Budapest and not announced yet but plan is I'm going to speak at the Budapest C++ meetup. We're thinking it's going to be... Oh no, it logged me out of Tripit, but I can go to just my calendar. It looks like it would be February 17th. Wow, so this might come out three days before February 17th. So if you are in Budapest probably not enough time to book a flight and fly there But if you're in the area, yeah, and then and then in March
End of March I'm gonna be in Paris and trying to set up something with the local Paris C++ meetup. And then in April, no sorry, not April. I think it's the last day of March. I think March 31st, I'm going to be in London and I'm going to be speaking at the London C++ meetup. And then hopefully sometime in New York, sometime in May, we're going to set up something in New York. And then in June, I'll be in Hamburg, and we're hopefully going to organize something.
That actually may be a bigger meetup with some other people from Nvidia. And then also I'll be in Sofia for the C++ committee meeting. And I'm not sure if they're going to organize a conference around then, but they did when they did the last C++ committee meeting in Bulgaria, and it was a great little event. I think just me and Bjarne were speakers, but it was a great little event. I think just me and
Bjarne were speakers but it was really well organized and hopeful they're gonna do something else there. So I'm gonna reach out to them see if they got something planned. And then the big exciting one is that in August we are going to meet my girlfriend and I are going to to East Africa. We are going to meet, my girlfriend and I are going to East Africa. We are going to Kenya, Ethiopia, and we'll briefly be in Tanzania in Zanzibar. And I'm trying to get connected with some folks to organize meetups in Kenya and Ethiopia. And I've been in contact with some folks in Kenya. Looks like that is underway.
But I have not been able to reach anyone in Ethiopia. So if you are in Ethiopia and you do tech things, C++ things, CUDA things, GPU things, and you're interested in helping to set up a meetup or you know some local tech meetups where I could give a talk at, please reach out to me. And I will resist the urge to try to organize a meetup during your wedding.
I mean, we can definitely record a podcast while we're down there for sure. I mean, that's just, podcast while we're down there for sure. I mean that's just You know why would we not do that? I'm gonna I'm gonna check with Shima on that before before we Know I know know don't you don't you don't you think you're gonna be like don't you think you're gonna be like? Super bit well I guess the thing is like you picked like a good Size for your wedding because
I feel like if you have a wedding where you have like 200 guests, like you're not going to see everybody at your wedding and if you do, you're going to get to spend like two minutes with each person. And so like you said you had like what, like less than 100 people or something? At the moment, yeah. If I go to our RSVP websites, which I haven't checked in a while to be honest, it currently says that 70 people are going. But that's not the full number.
This is where like, what is it, 10 months away? And also too, I'm trying to figure out the stats is not I went to, oh, I see we're on I'm on the wrong. I'm on I got too many podcasts. I tried to go check, because there's, in the stats section of ADSP's hosting site, shout out to, yeah, should we plug this site? And now, well, reach out to them.
Maybe they can start, I paid this company too much money, because I got too many podcasts, and they charged me for each one. Maybe we should we should We should reach out and say hey, can I have my money back? If we mention you like once every couple podcasts or not money back Can we just like not pay money going forward man this website is so slow though? It's like taking like since I started talking to load the stats all right here. We go we go to locations and Just in the last five episodes,
we've had 186 downloads from Africa. If we go, I guess we'll just stick with that. We'll stick with that. What are the African countries? One you were just in, Morocco, Kenya, Algeria. I have to eyeball this, Rwanda, that's already we're down to four and Ethiopia is not on that list. I gotta say, Morocco would be an excellent place to host a C++ conference or meetup
because it's very easy to get to Morocco from the east coast of the United States. It's easy to get there from Europe. It's a beautiful country, great food, very friendly people. We had an excellent time. It's pretty accessible to North Africa and parts of Central Africa. Yeah. And Zimbabwe was the last one. So now, that's only the last five episodes. I just hit all episodes, which I now, I assume is just gonna cause their server to fall over.
Because getting the stats on the last five took like 10 seconds. And I will let you know how many, or actually, wait, I said last five episodes, and then it said 186 downloads, and then I proceeded to say that the five episodes led to it only being five countries. So I don't know why that is how my logic worked. I should just search for the word.
I searched for ETH. Here's a little fun game. Only one country came up and it was the 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7th country on the list of rankings of countries that had downloads. Can you name the country that has the substring ETH in it, that is number seven on our list. What a fun game, folks. Play along, listener. And I'll give a hint if you can't come up with it in the next little bit. Give me a second here. Give me a second here.
I think I just gotta think about this. You better not be going to an LLM. I hope you're just going to Google Maps. No. I guess it would be probably the Netherlands. Woo, you got it folks, he got it. That was fun, that was fun. That was a good one.
I didn't think, that's hard to think of. I'm not sure I would have gotten that. I mean, there can't be that many with ETH in there, right? The stats have loaded. When I said I was gonna look at all the stats folks, however many seconds ago or minutes ago that was, it just finally loaded Which I guess is maybe forgivable because we're like close to a million downloads, so they're they're doing a lot of
partitioning stuff, so if I go see all countries now and 18,000 downloads from the continent of Africa Ethiopia has had 271 downloads so at some point someone probably not just one person because we don't have 271 downloads. So at some point, someone, probably not just one person, because we don't have 271 episodes, at least two people have listened from Ethiopia. They just, I don't know, you either offended them. I imagine it would have been you that offended them, not me. Or they just have an irregular listening pattern and they might be listening before August.
So if you do happen to be one of the handful of folks that listens in Ethiopia and you're interested in helping Bryce out. Yeah, reach out to me. Hit him up. You can reach me on email. You can reach me on the X. You can reach me on LinkedIn. Lots of places. So where are you gonna be? Oh, and I should say, last place I'm gonna be, but I'm probably not gonna do a meetup because it's gonna be purely vacation, but we're gonna be in Tokyo and then Vietnam, Cambodia, and Thailand for the holidays next year.
Ooh, that's gonna be nice. So I suppose I would say that if someone really, really, really wanted us to speak at an event in Thailand or Vietnam or even Tokyo around the holidays, you could reach out and I could try to clear it with the girlfriend. Yeah. So what about you? What's your travel going to look like for this year? Honestly, I haven't made any you ping me about this the other day.
I have a document at Google Doc. I love Google Docs folks. Another tangent. I love applications. Whether that is a website or a phone. I guess it has to be a website because it's desktop based. If you have emoji colon completion, like colon start typing the name of the emoji. I love it.
I love it, folks. I love it. And I technically do have like an emoji program installed where I can bring up something, but just being able in place to do that and Google Docs has that now. Colon you start typing. It's fantastic. It also has if you copy and paste YouTube links you can tab complete to get like a little
kind of YouTube hyperlink preview with a little YouTube thing. I love Google Docs. I bring this up because I have one, two, three, four, five, six spreadsheets in my bookmark bar. We'll go through them. They are named ADSP, Arraycast, Wedding, Wait, POW, which is not Prisoners of War. It is Portfolio of Words. I migrated my spreadsheet to a Google Sheet and then Finance. And then we have four documents that are just Google Docs. Goals, RTW, Cal, which is short for calories, and diet. And RTW is the one we're gonna talk about. It is running the world.
Oh, I thought so. Okay, yeah. Which is, it has become, it started out as just places that I was traveling to that was either gonna be a new country or a place that I was traveling to that was either gonna be a new country Or a place that I hadn't run a street in or a place. I might be for like a week or so Because I get very excited there's like I still remember when I went to the Northwest Territories last year with Shima and
I was like man. We're there for like eight days I'm probably gonna be able to hammer out this whole city and I was able to run 97% of it in like eight days of running like 20k a day and also too there was a city called Nadillo probably pronouncing that wrong N-D-I-L-O with a couple accents on the the vowels or something and it was like 12 streets so my first run I went a 20k run and I hammered out an entire municipality with 12 streets it was I was a few things in life get me as excited as completing streets in like a single or a city in a single run
anyways but I have started to add conferences and just basically any travel whether it's running related or not and currently these are the conferences that I have added the dates no indication that I'm going to these it's just like maybe I would want to go. And some of these, the CFPs are already closed. The first one is PyCon in May of 2025. I think a couple different people told me about the CFP closing back in December.
I honestly have been rejected the last two years from PyCon and I couldn't really think of anything. I mean, ironically, now I definitely have something to talk about because you and Jake were telling me that I should be looking at SciPy or PyCon. What I've heard about PyCon is that PyCon wants to hear, like they want to see talks on like established things is what I've heard, is like that they want talks on like established like existing things and that it can be hard to get a talk on like something like new and novel accepted in it at PyCon. That PyCon's less like CppCon where like you can talk about some new bold thing where PyCon wants to be more a little bit more like Educational and like
Oriented for the masses and for beginners and so because of that they really focus on like things that are established that are existing best Practice I don't even know if my PyCon talks gonna get accepted. Yeah, that's fair enough It's more though that, yeah, I just, at the time I went to sit down right before the deadline to like, I had written out a couple talks that I was interested in giving in 2025, and none of them were like, I thought PyCon suitable. Most of them were like functional programming composition,
you know, array programming-esque. And so it didn't seem like a good fit. Anyways, we'll rattle through the, and so I honestly don't have plans on, like, obviously not going to PyCon because I didn't submit a talk. The next one I have is Lambda days in the middle of June. I don't think I'll be going to this one,
but there's a chance that I might end up being in Europe in June, in which case, yeah, I might pop over. Although I think the CFP closes or is closing soon. By the time you're listening to this it might be closed then PLDI 2025 I would only go talk talk I would only go to that conference if I got a paper accepted to the array workshop
Which I may or may not submit one Then there's the two NDC talks in September Copenhagen and tech town Which is in Kongsberg which got mentioned either in this episode or the one before. I don't think yeah like I said I don't really have plans to go to those that's gonna be right before not right before a couple months before my wedding. Then Dialogue the APL company might be doing some kind of meetup or mini conference in the states I've heard of. That's nothing is announced there.
Minnowbrook which is a APL conference I went to in the past. That is something I'd love to go to but once again information on that isn't out yet. And then Lambda World is at the end of October. Probably not gonna go to that because it's like a week or two before my wedding. Anyway, so I have a lot of stuff on my radar, but I don't actually have official plans to go to any of this If oh, yeah, and I didn't mention it I don't know why it's actually not on this list the one conference I do know that I will definitely be going to is CBP North
Because I do not have to travel to go to CP CPP North and the dates for that if Yes, I actually have it right here. It's a July 20th to 23rd July 20th it is now going in the the Google Doc. I just shared with you my my Calendar of things Or my my my sheet with with trips. Oh, it's via email. I assume or something like that I shared it with oh did I share with you? I think I did Yeah, yeah, yeah anyways all this to say it's a
Usually I'll tell myself. Oh, it'll be a light conference year, but then at some point I get really excited about some topic and then But that's the thing is like there's conferences that it's so early in the year that like they haven't opened their CFP. I gotta go through sometime today and write down when everybody opens up their their CFPs but you know I've been looking at some of the other NDC conferences and also there's this series of conferences called aox that look kind of interesting. And then there's this, so I was looking at my, you introduced me to this app for tracking
what countries you've been to. And then of course I realized that you'd been to more countries than me and then immediately got jealous and was like, all right, we gotta fix that. I told Ramon, like, you know, we're going to Vietnam. Like, we may as well just stop into Cambodia just for like a day or two just so I can cross it off the list. You shouldn't be competing with me. Shima's been to like 50 or 60 countries.
I know. Do you know how many you've been to? I think it's like 32. Let me check. I think it's like 32. Let me check. I ran into, I was at my middle school, my middle school starting an alumni association and one of my friends from my class in middle school, he was there on the founding call and we chatted a little bit and he's doing some really cool stuff. His name is Jacob Komar and he mentioned that he's been to like 59 countries and travels like you know like 80 or 90 percent of the year because he actually has a production company for like streamers and stuff like that and I was like oh wow like 50 countries like I gotta I gotta up my game but I'll show you I don't know if this how am I got to up my game, but I'll show you. I don't know how well this is going to show up on the screen. I'm going to send you a screenshot, but out of Europe, the only places that I've not been to in Europe that we can currently go to is a couple of the Baltic countries, so no Latvia, Lithuania, Estonia, were going to Portugal for Thanksgiving, but then Denmark, haven't been to Denmark, been to every other
Scandinavian country, but not Denmark. And so I want to get Denmark. So I'm looking for a Denmark conference or something. There's this Copenhagen Developers Festival that I heard about somewhere. It looks pretty cool. I think unfortunately, the dates are going to be when we're going to be in Africa this year. But I don't know, maybe I'll try to find some other conference out there. But anyways, we should do the 2025 predictions, right?
Oh yeah, we've got only, well, it's all right, we've got a few minutes, so yes, let's do a couple 2025 predictions. Hot takes, top three, program-related, non-programming-related general? Go. Oh, boy. Well, I would say that I definitely think you and I are going to be talking a lot less about C++ and a lot more about other languages over the course of this year. And I feel like there's a general, it's a little bit of a shift at least for like this sort of code that we interact with, which is like more compute heavy code like data science, you know, HPC stuff like that. I see more and more of that moving to like DSLs into Python and DSLs built in Python. And I think that's a trend that's going to continue. People are still going to write libraries
and lower level code, at least to some degree, in languages like C++, but I think we're going to see more and more applications moving towards other languages into DSLs and higher level languages. I mean that's a trend that's been going on for a long while but I think in particular for us and for the spaces that we're in, which is really compute, we're going to see a lot more of that. that. I suspect that we'll talk more about AI and machine learning. A bold prediction, a bold prediction there. What company do you work for again? I don't know whether we're going to see orders of magnitude
advances, though. I feel like maybe it's like with the self-driving cars, where we saw a lot of advances really quickly, but then there's that last 10% that's sort of hard to reach. So I don't know. Maybe we'll be surprised. But is it going to be a rapid acceleration, or is it going to be a little bit slower from here on out?
Other things that we might talk about, I think we will probably talk more about Rust within the next year. And I think that we will talk more on this podcast about programming language design for a variety of reasons that I don't think we can share with the listeners yet. But I think we'll talk more about programming language design. And yeah, I guess C++ 26 will come out. I suspect that C++ 26 will be a pretty big release.
I think we'll get reflection. I think we'll probably get a little bit more of reflection than we think. I think we're going to get, obviously, we're going to get senders, which has already been in for a while. I think contracts will happen. I think we'll end up doing some set of things in the name of safety.
Maybe we'll get some form of profiles. But I think when we step back in three to six months, C++26 is going to look like a pretty big release. And people are going to be pretty excited about it and about the scale of what we're looking at. the scale of what we're looking at. But I don't think that's going to change this trend of people, especially people who are in C++
leadership positions starting to think about C++ more and more of a legacy language. So I think despite the successes of C++ 26, that's going to continue to be the perspective. And I think that we will see fewer, we will see successor languages like things that are attempting to be C++ 2.0. I think we're going to see more and more of those disappear over the next year because we've talked before about how it's really hard for a new language to come in and disrupt the incumbent. I think there's only really space for one or two to do that.
I think Rust has gotten enough momentum behind it that Rust is going to be the successor language, especially with the drive for safety and the fears about regulation and regulatory concerns. I think that Rust is just going to be the thing that we're going to all turn towards. So I think there's going to be a consolidation in the systems programming world around Rust as the future.
And I think some of these projects to build C++ successors are going to maybe start to close up shop. What about you? What are your predictions? I mean, those are all great predictions. I mean, the AI, LLM, or machine learning, I guess, is what you said. Is that really a prediction?
I think the sky could be blue some of the days. But I put out some caution. I said that I don't know that we're going to see. I think we'll see more adoption of the large language model technology that exists today. I don't know that we're gonna see Radical breakthroughs in new technology, but there's just a lot of room to just adopt what currently exists Yeah, I will counter that prediction with
the opposite I think I don't necessarily know if there's gonna be like, you know, a GPT, you know 2.5 to 3 and 4 like those step functions. I think there's gonna be some improvements, but I think it's just gonna be adopted more and my prediction, my actual prediction coming out of this topic is that the rise of the 100x developer will occur. You know, some people say 10x dev is not really a thing. I definitely know a handful, if not more, of developers that I've met across the three companies I've worked for during my, we'll call it generously a short career.
And they are, I would say like on average 10x better, if not more. They are people that I refer to as like wizards that are just very productive, very good. And I think that those people are now going to be another order of magnitude better than like your average dev because what you are able to do and I think that it enables too like your 1x dev to become a 10x dev like the the tool that profiling tool in like an hour or two because of code completion and like LLMs and It is just it is the power of being able to like, you know that scene in inception when
What's what's the actors name? They're the actor from Juno, but they construct the dreams. They're the dream constructor. And her character goes in with Leonardo DiCaprio and he's explaining, oh yeah, you can change things. You're the architect. And then she realizes that like, oh, I can do anything. And she starts Flipping the world upside down and folding it in on
Itself you remember that scene. Yeah, that's what it feels like to have an LLM at your fingertips anyway, so I think the the rise of the 100x developer and I mean you There's one person that and I know you know who I have in mind, who I know exactly. I wonder whether this person. They're going to become a 1000x death. Yeah, but I wonder whether he uses them today. I'm going to ask. I'm going to ask.
I said they to, what's the word, obfuscate the gender, now you've given you've given the listener a hint. By the time this is published it's all gonna be out there. I still you know and we're gonna respect his privacy and not say anything here, although we should have them on at some point but yeah. Yeah so I just think that yeah for and I've foo- and I've heard too, I was listening to an interview with, I don't know his name, can't remember it, but he is the individual that was previously, I think, the CEO of HashiCorp and is now the main developer of the Ghosty Terminal emulator, which has had a lot of hype recently, it's being written in Zig. And he basically says that like whenever the network networks down, internet's down, he just
like stops working because he's just like it's not worth his time if he doesn't have access to these like code completion tools because he's just like, well, I guess I'm done for the day. Anyways, that's my prediction. 100x devs, your ability to build things is just, it's just, it feels so cool. Like I said, insert a clip of the folding the city in on itself. My question is, what happens when you start messing with the physics of it all? I'm not sure if I'm going to die here. Something isn't it? Yes it is.
Other predictions, what some hot takes. I mean, Rust, I've predicted the last two or three years on my YouTube channel that Rust would become a top 10 language according to my PLRank.com site. It has not happened and I've realized that's because the gap in the average ranking, it has a lot to close. Right now Go is in the tenth spot with an average language ranking across Stack Overflow, Octoverse, Redbunk, and Languish of 10.25. Rust is sitting at number 11 with an average ranking of 13.33. So that's more than three average ranking spots. So it would really need to go up on one or two of these ranking sites. So do I think Rust is going to break into the top 10?
I don't think so. I actually don't think so for the first time in like two or three years. You'd think that we'd be closer than ever now, but not really. I don't know. I want to make a programming language prediction. What would be a hot take? Let's take a look at the functional languages. Gleam jumped into the top 20 and went from 17th to 13th. Maybe we'll predict that Gleam breaks into the top 10. And what is my third prediction? My third prediction alongside the 100x developer, unfortunately. I mean this might be a bit bit controversial because I think Zuckerberg a lot of controversial tech people at the moment. Oh, yeah, maybe maybe we can talk about that too for a couple of seconds. I don't know. I'll chat about that later. Keep that off air. But you know, Zuckerberg said that he was going to replace a bunch of his employees with LLMs. I think that
that that is not false. I think that is he is being truthful when he says that. And that is not false. I think that he is being truthful when he says that. And that is going to be a trend across companies that employ software developers, is that there is going to be less opportunities, probably layoffs. And the 10x devs that become 100x devs are going to replace teams of people and for better or for worse that
She she was eating a banana she just wandered over because she's listening to what I'm saying it's not in her head going Would you like to say something we're making predictions about 2023 you got any Would you like to say something? We're making predictions about 2023. You got any predictions? 2025 not 2023. 2025, my bad. I don't know what happened there for a moment. She's got a banana.
She's eaten the banana. And are we still buying? This is actually I said we were going to keep this off air. Are we still going to buy a Tesla? I am 34 turning 35 have never owned a car in my life, vowed that I would buy an EV, stands for electric vehicle, for those that aren't familiar with the acronym, and I feel bad, given, I know it's been a month, but if you've forgotten what's happened right after the inauguration,
Elon's in a little bit of hot water, whether or not you think he was- You're not putting this on air, right? What? You're not airing it. Yeah, this is- we're recording the podcast. Shima just said you're not putting this on air, right? Yeah, we're recording the podcast. Shima just said you're not putting this on the air, are you? Anyway, it's a little bit controversial, but we still want to buy the Tesla
because Shima's sister and brother-in-law both have Teslas and the FSD full self-driving, folks. 13.0. It is phenomenal. It makes me feel like a bad driver. It makes me feel like every person I'm in a car with when I'm in an Uber is a bad driver.
It's so good. And I feel like we need to divorce the art from the artists so that I can own a Tesla guilt-free. Bryce has things to say. Well, I was just gonna say, we get a lot of rental cars. And so I have some opinions on cars because we just get to experience a lot of different types of cars.
About a year ago, we had a rental somewhere and the only thing they had available for us was electric vehicles. They gave us one of the Kia EV6s, their crossover SUV thing. the lady at the rental car agency, she was like, oh, I think you're really going to like it. Like, I prefer these over the Teslas. And we drove it, and we really loved it. I don't know that the self-driving, like it has self-driving features that are probably
not as advanced as Teslas. But as a car, I think it's a better car. If you want the Tesla just for the self-driving features, yeah, they're probably gonna be the boldest and the first to market. But if you want like a better car, like I think the Kia EDs are really, really strong. A couple problems with everything you just said.
First of all, you said when we drove it, that's your number one problem right there. Second of all, you said first to market, it's already your number one problem right there. Second of all, you said first to market. It's already here. Thirteen point oh, it's already here, folks. Why do you need a car? We're going to be probably moving out of the city. Well, I don't. Well, yes, probably.
We're probably we're going to try and you know, what do you call it? Like move to the next level of our life. We're living in as we like to call it, a shoebox. Yeah. And we need more space. And I've lived my life long enough. And also too, we tend to visit family more often now, which is irritating to do via transit
if you're going that frequently, because it's like an hour plus away and it's only like a 20 minute drive. I absolve you of your guilt. I absolve you of your guilt. Well that's the thing is I I don't really have guilt I just want to I don't want to be canceled because you know like people are leaving Twitter and it's just like just because I'm keeping my Twitter profile it doesn't mean I support the people that are running it. It's just that I get more engagement on Twitter than I do on any of the other platforms. Like everyone's saying,
oh man, everybody moved to Mastodon, everybody moved to Blue Sky. That's not true. It's not true. I now have been posting on all three platforms, every post that I do. And in general, sometimes on Mastodon, depending on the type of post, I might get a little bit more interaction. But on average, Twitter is still the place where there's the largest community and I knew I just like I understand why people are it makes me feel so good that you said that because I've been I've been thinking more and more lately should I be going and building you know should I be going and doing my social media somewhere else it feels like there's fewer and fewer people on Twitter.
It makes me feel so good that you're validating my laziness. I will say, folks, it is mostly laziness and exhaustion. If people keep asking me why I'm not on the other platforms, it's because having to take on another social media and messaging platform and having to think about that and having to deal with that is a lot of mental energy for me. And I'm not sure that I want to take that on. If there's any place that I would be likely to post
more stuff, it would probably be on LinkedIn, just because that's an existing thing. And I already have some number of people that reach out to me about things on LinkedIn. I'm not sure that I'm ready to go and commit to some new platform. And that's the thing, I would love to get off of Twitter but like while there is a larger community of tech folks and also too like I hear stuff about the toxicity and the policies and in my tech corner of Twitter, which is mostly programming language, C++ and array people, array language people, I have very rarely encountered anything and if I do, I just block the person. And people, I know that, I don't even really understand, I know I think Blue Sky or Macedon, they allow you to block words and stuff.
But I never encounter things, like I'm not saying it doesn't exist, I'm just saying in my little corner of Twitter, it doesn't seem that bad. I have heard that it is not great for a lot of folks, but that hasn't been my experience. Anyways, I just, I feel like we live in an interesting time where, you know, like I said, Elon does some controversial things, and now I am like like I still want FSD FSD is
for me like transcends not wanting to support someone because of their Political leanings or whatever but then I also you know, it is a question of you know, do you get an inferior product? When it comes to self-driving, I don't know. It's an interesting question. Stay tuned, folks. Does Connor buy a Tesla? I mean, I think there's nothing wrong with buying a Tesla if you so choose. I appreciate that. I appreciate that. You can be my conscience on this one. Anyways, I'm not sure.
One could argue that Elon doesn't even really run Tesla or do anything at Tesla because he's too busy going off doing crazy Elon stuff elsewhere. Yeah, that's true. He's become oligarch, whatever, quasi politician, runner of Doge and fire air of people. Yeah. To what extent does he actually run the day-to-day operations of any of his companies is... I have no idea, but I wouldn't be surprised if it's less than people think. Yeah, yeah. I have been thinking... I did download Blue Sky and I do think I've had an account on there since it was invite only, but I've not even set it up or done anything with it. I have noticed that I do feel like I get less engagement on Twitter, but also that's partially
because a large amount of my tweets now are just about random travel stuff. But also I feel like follower growth is not what it once was on Twitter. Maybe that's just because I don't pay for Twitter, because I don't see a point in paying for Twitter. Again, I don't want to give in. I don't want to give in to the man. I wouldn't say it's a good place, but it's where I am. And on that note. I do think I'll probably post more on LinkedIn because I've been noticing more engagement on LinkedIn
and I've been noticing more people like posting stuff on LinkedIn. And yeah, I may move more content to LinkedIn. You heard it here first, folks. Go follow Bryce on LinkedIn. Yes. Happy New first, folks. Go follow Bryce on LinkedIn. Yes. Happy New Year, folks. Happy New Year, folks.
Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.